The name is out now.
Bin Longboard's 3rd Congressional candidate.
M. G.
LAN,
the Federal President to my colleagues on the Longboards candidates of the A.
M. G.
Ler and Gerhard Schloß of the support just collect
that one just the last and only,
ladies and gentlemen,
the beer crate,
dear friends of the free voters,
dear friends of common sense,
welcome to the bierzeug,
ladies and gentlemen,
pre-developed with common sense.
It is our Central Embassy In crazy times our society
is still driven apart left and right
here an AfD now 2030 and more percent dead,
where it must be said that people are insecure.
People always know who to turn to.
And there was simply the oversight and failure
of the Politician Union in recent years.
There are still many inside the little people who enjoyed the song God,
in the civil he remains nothing else than to choose us anyway.
And you moved further and further to the left.
More and more Greens have been brought into state governments.
In the meantime,
the Greens in the federal government and their predecessors have
it quite clear that I don't want a Green in the
Bavarian state government in the fall,
ladies and gentlemen.